[Music]
let's go to yo joe in los angeles
california what's up joe
hey john how you doing man we are
rocking on to the brink of dawn man how
are you
it is a it's a day it's a day it's been
one of those weeks yes sir it has it has
the world went sideways
um man so what's up how can i help
uh
so uh like lots of folks um trying to
pick up the pieces uh
some
context uh i have i had a brain injury
um a long long time ago uh left me with
some residual damage in my
an associated
disconnects
which i think you may know about um
but
i
long story short
i have you know
very very rare but very serious when
they happen outbursts um
that a lot of times people with brain
injuries
do um but what are your outbursts
consists of
uh self
harm um where i'll be hitting myself i
will
um
go into like a very what i would
perceive in the moment uh i guess like a
a safe space like a bathroom or a closet
or something and i'll just start like
yelling am i not yelling but like
repeating um at myself you know very
angry things what uh what unwinds you
when you when you
hit that switch what is able to bring
you back
silence um
knowing that
honestly myself uh since my brain injury
i've been to you know
20 plus neurologist psychologists of
course there's family counselors yeah
and i self-administer uh i'm not telling
you this definitely the wrong word i
um definitely go through the process of
even outside of my family helping me
helping myself with doctors and
neurologists and therapists
they have even submitted myself into
clinical trials at different
universities
a group
which
i'm going to leave the name out but
they're pretty well known in the brain
world
right the brain scan world um
been working with them um trying to
narrow down what it is that's causing my
outbursts okay uh can we
stop for a second i want everybody to
hear this
um
and this is just dude there's just two
guys hanging out in the back of a
tailgate
in a like on a backup truck in a parking
lot
i
i can't think of a scarier thing in the
world knowing that
at certain moments when i unpredict
unprovoked and and somewhat
unpredictable
my own brain turns on me that's a fear
that very few of us walk through the
world with and man i just want to say
i'm sorry i hate that for you
you know i appreciate that but i
the way my brain works i have a lot of
issues with executive decision making um
which is why i honestly my
the parts of my brain that were affected
were the executive decision making parts
um what was that what was the it was the
injury acute what was it
um i i sustained a brain injury after
hitting getting hit by a vehicle um i
was in a coma for a month forgot you
know
a lot of my life uh most of it honestly
before the injury and uh
you know a lot of um memory recall
issues but i also have this savant like
memory
um
storage thing where you know i can i
know it's there the memories are there i
just can't access them but then if i
have a trigger which is you know through
different senses sensories
um those triggers can put me to a near
you know photographic
state of you know being um but the the
issues of me um i i'm i'm in a process a
path you know where i'm gonna get better
you know every day gets a little bit
a little better two steps forward and
the
you know two steps back but at least i
know i can keep moving and eventually
it'll i'll break through through that
but
where my question is is um
man i've i've been an [ __ ] to my wife
um yeah i don't for some reason i have
the ability to control myself
verbally i've never been a physical
person period for anybody but
i've uh
i've said some mean things in those
moments
the outbursts only happen when i'm with
you know either my family member or
by myself
and again they have like once or twice a
year that i've had this since my injury
that it's like gotten to the point where
i break
but uh
it's unfortunately my wife is usually
present when it happens um
and
i've said
i've said things at me
i mean i'm not gonna
get into details but i've said you know
i called my wife you know [ __ ] and i
said
i'm not gonna say it on funnier
yeah but
um
and i don't remember
doing it and i'm not gonna i know i said
it i can't deny it i don't know how to
stop it it's not things i think of her i
stopped things i
but now i've been living in a hotel for
the last month or a couple a week
starting a month okay so is she done
it feels like it yeah
when's your most recent outburst
uh
it would have been
about 10 days ago okay and then
i went to the bathroom uh closed i
turned the shower on and started
hitting myself in the head i don't know
what happened um
what triggered it i think we had a very
menial argument
um
and then yeah i went to the bathroom
started like
not hating myself but just like
doing i guess uh
nervous tapping
aggressive tapping i'll say that because
it wasn't i know when i if i hit myself
i've never bruised myself so i'm not
like trying to
kill myself um
in that point or like leave lasting
damage just
something that i do since my injury i
don't know why but so what is your what
is your wife
saying i'm out i'm done
uh i can't live like this
i
the quote is i'm not i i can't be
emotionally attached to you and i
understand that yeah she's
not a therapist she's not a psychologist
and i
met her when she was you know a
very young adult they're not very young
adults she was very early 20s and
yeah so man i'm sorry dude
and i don't know
how to
so she lost the guy that she knew right
did she know you pre pre-accident
pre-car wreck no okay so she's met you
since then so how long have you all been
together
ten uh a decade yeah a decade man decade
we've lived together for seven and we've
been married for three and when did the
outbursts begin
um i mean
as far as i i
know they were regular outbursts when i
had my injury and i was you know a
teenager um and my parents you know they
had
how many times have you gone after her
like you did the other day
three times
uh the way i did yeah three times i
think
and it's it's it
you know i i had a very good job um very
very good job we're actually a series of
very good jobs uh
and then you know that happened and i
lost the job and i
this is the context that you're missing
or that i think you might not i don't
think i mentioned this but you know i
did try to kill myself um a couple years
ago uh
and i don't ideate anymore like i know
that i know now because of all the money
i've spent you know
on those scams in my brain that i know
why i ideate so i know like at least
i know it's not like some part of me
that wants to kill myself it's just in
the brain that's like you know working
the right way there you go and it's
overacting and a part of my brain that
is saying hey hurt yourself kill
yourself you don't belong here sure
but you know
um so has she been able to come back
from that that can be devastating on a
relationship
no um no
it's been a long uh the first
year feeling sorry for myself afterwards
you know not trying to report not trying
to even recover just
and you know still trying to apply for
work i'm still trying to apply for
different jobs and getting work you know
and i had money saved up after my work
my my job that i lost you know we were
okay with money i was able to take trips
once in a while but so bring me bring me
down to how can i help you man you i
know you got so much going on i'm glad
that you're getting the help that you
need and you're surrounded by the best
you know the best experts in the world
how can i help you man
um
you know i've been listening to
the show the last couple days and it's
been honestly giving me the answers i
needed um but i think the first question
i had
when i initially called to see if i
could get on the show was
how can i save my marriage like
everybody um that are like so many
people but now it's
i i want to save my marriage um but i
also want my wife to be with somebody
not that she has she needs to do
something she's completely
independent woman and she's so amazing i
watch everything she does
i want i i
like i think i'm just looking for
the
inspiration to help the the
the
you know the the good ending story where
you know they they still are in each
other's lives and
where she can trust me again because
her
a former uh partner of hers
um
did lose his life
that way uh okay so she's got a history
of trauma too and this is a story that
she's seen play out right and in her
mind and her body she knows how the
story ends
and
um
that's terrifying for anybody
here's two things i hear number one
she took herself or you know you took
yourself out of a situation where i
don't want to hurt somebody that i love
and i think that's noble and good
what makes me uncomfortable is your
language is shifting to
she deserves somebody that and what that
language means is you are starting to
view yourself as a burden to her
and when you do that you know what
happens next
because burden talk
relational burden talk
is the last of the trifecta of why am i
even here anymore people would be better
off if i wasn't here
and so i know you tell me you're done
ideating and all that i don't like the
trajectory of the language you're using
am i onto something or tell me i'm crazy
you are um okay
so hear me say this
i do think
if you scared your wife
if you yelled and screamed and got in
her face and called her
horrid things
yeah and so and i do want to add i i've
you know
everything's a progress everything's
worth it you know
and when we first met um again i've
never put my hands on her i never put my
hands on anybody in my life sure but i i
would not i wouldn't understand certain
cues and i would like we would be
getting in a very you know
sometimes loud
we yell each other and because neither
of us grew up in environments where
people talk to each other like we're
talking now even though like we've both
been working on it sure
but you know i used to not understand
social cues like oh i can't you know
corner my wife in the bathroom so now
what i do is i put my hands up in the
air like i back away so she kind of gets
those cues like i'm not trying to push
you in the corner i'm not sure i'm
trying to make sure you know like
yeah
and i i think i overstepped because i
put myself into a place where i i
look at myself like i'm a mop like this
monster which i've never been a physical
monster i've never been that's right and
listen listen to me listen to me
i'm not i'm not accusing you of that
okay no i know
we're not teddy we don't make fun of
each other we don't poke holes at each
other we just don't do that sure she's
never ever done that to me she's never
and we don't i don't do that to her like
we don't belittle each other yes she
knows who she married that that the
person she married
well she didn't know that that's that's
the problem because i had 10 years yeah
10 years okay so
um
let me
i was very high functioning that's
that's great i should know signs okay um
but the the reality is here's where we
are
okay
i do think
that there is a chance that your
marriage can be i think there's a great
chance your marriage can be saved
i also think that in this particular
moment
a little bit of space between the two of
you is a wise thing
and that's not doesn't mean that the
thing is over now
and you say things when you are having a
brain a storm is what i've known to call
them the neurological storm
when your brain's trying to talk to
itself and it's not communicating with
itself well
and
man when you have those storms
and somebody's on the receiving end of
that it is wise for them to back out
okay that doesn't mean unplug forever
my oldest friend on planet earth the
oldest friend i have
um
has a traumatic brain injury
and i know by the emails i get by the
conversations we have
i'm not even going to respond to this
because he is storming in a way
that makes him think that we are having
a conversation that we had 25 years ago
30 years ago 35 years ago
and my best course of action is to
unplug for a week or two
okay that's the that's the best thing we
do and then i circle back and we're good
and he's got people in his life who love
him and walk alongside him and care for
him and so it's very similar so what i'm
telling you is it is wise and safe and
smart for your wife to back out right
now you scared the crap out of her and
yeah
everybody in this world knows you didn't
do that on purpose
okay
you've you're walking through something
i i i
i don't know if i didn't do it on a
purpose because i don't recall these
moments happening and here's what i'm
telling you listen to me you didn't do
it on purpose joe
okay
and i appreciate you saying that but i
also there are other people that are
listening i'm sure that i i want to make
sure folks know that i don't see myself
as a victim whatsoever
quit apologizing you're a good man
you're a good man with some some major
challenges nobody's feeling sorry for
you we're walking alongside you
you can say right now
i have a very specific question then you
know okay go for it
here's the question
if i truly love someone which i do and i
know that they i think that they love me
still um
how
they i i the first half of our life
together i showed no signs of a brain
injury i was completely normal like
atypical functioning normal person um
and i'd say that you know we're still
normal with even with brain injuries
it's just a little more difficult all
right so the question you know if
she was not braised and she doesn't
necessarily have that same foundation
and that support network i do um it's
just true um i have
family i have friends i have people all
over the country that i could go to i
don't
she doesn't necessarily have that same
support group okay give me your question
and she also doesn't have she doesn't
have she doesn't have an education she's
an education in brain um and in you know
in neurology she's not a neurologist
she's not she doesn't have the training
and she doesn't necessarily have the
time get to your question
what are you telling me how do how do i
like how does she deal with me like how
does someone like me like
give her the space and she respect
how does she just deal with me like how
here's how here's how here's how
yeah um your relationship is not special
in this regard
the particular challenge within your
relationship is
but your relationship as a whole is not
it's what me and my wife went through
it's what james and his wife went
through it's what kelly and her husband
with it's what we all go through
which is
i make a decision
to lean in and say i want to know as
much about you as possible
i want to know how i can love you better
what are your turn-ons and not just
sexual what are the things that bring
you peace and joy in your life and what
are the things i can do that contribute
to the offs
everyone has those in their
relationships and the relationships that
make it are the ones that remain curious
as people grow and change which we all
do
when we find out new things when
somebody has been married for seven
years and then they have a daughter and
all of a sudden the trauma of their
sexual abuse as a kid comes flooding
back and nobody saw it coming and the
husband's sitting there going i don't
have any experience with this and he
chooses
to go get counseling himself to go to
marriage counseling to go to trauma
therapy so he learns the words to take a
local community college class for free
or for 350 bucks or whatever it is
to read every book you possibly can to
listen to podcasts like this it becomes
a way of life
because that way of life is love now
here's what i'm going to tell you if you
love her
you will not take her autonomy away to
love you back
that's not love
you can't preemptively say i love you so
much i'm cutting this thing off so that
you can't whatever whatever so that you
don't get whatever whatever you don't
get to do that if you love her love says
i'm going to walk alongside her as she
chooses whether she's in or out
and if she chooses in i'm going to go to
her with with her to the classes i'm
going to go to her uh with her i'm going
to let her come to my appointments with
me so she can begin to learn and get a
context and have the psychiatrist and
the neurologist and all the brain
scientists that are walking alongside
you look at her and say when this
happens
you need to call this number and he
needs to leave the house for a day
that's part of life it's if if if i have
a disorder where if i eat gluten and i
vomit everywhere
if i happen to get gluten and i throw up
all over the house
you know what i mean like i we have a
plan now
whatever that happens to be your plan is
exceptional let's be super clear you've
got a traumatic brain injury that sounds
like it's been with you for a long time
and you are busting your
butt to heal
healing though can't be done in a vacuum
you can't heal by yourself joe you got
to bring her along with you
and you got to tell her i'm deeply sorry
i'm healing you are walking alongside me
from this point forward i'm not doing
this alone anymore
we're married we're in this together and
if she says i'm out that's the grown-up
choice she makes that will be
heartbreaking and devastating and it
does not mean
that it's all on you it does not mean
that somehow you failed you've got
challenges that you have to have
somebody to walk alongside you in those
challenges are they different yeah are
they hard yep
the apology comes as i accidentally hurt
you
in a state of
that was that was
directly correlated to my injury
i caused you hurt and comps i'm
heartbroken i'm so sorry
here's what i'm gonna do to continue to
work to get better please join me in
that
joe listen to me carefully
you're worth love
the world is going to be worse if you're
not in it the world's better because
you're in it
your fighting spirit and your bravery
will lift up your communities and the
listeners of the show
and it's time to stop trying to protect
her as much as allow her to walk
alongside you
allow her to walk alongside you
and keep
grinding keep growing keep getting
better keep getting better keep getting
better